meantime employees and the public  administrator's office said they  reported telus's Behavior to County  officials but those officials told them  they couldn't do anything because he was  an elected official Clark County  Commissioner tick sagerbloom told  politics now host John langler he wants  to correct those mistakes  I would want to justify it I think we  screwed up big time but hopefully you  learned from the past and and so we're  all much more Vigilant about what goes  on to those especially those what we  call Independent agencies and one of the  things we're going to do is go to the  legislature has to have those positions  taken out of the election cycle that  there's no  we get good people in historically we've  had good people but there truthfully  there's no reason to have them elected  you can watch that full interview on  politics now that airs Saturday at 11  35.